when the drag queen Story Hour stuff
started everyone started saying hey this
is grooming and the immediate defense
from the left was no no no they're just
reading books and you'd come out and
you'd say yeah but drag queen
performances are removal of clothes
accepting of cash on stage he's very kin
to bikini bars or stripping and they say
it's just reading a book then they
started doing all they just drag dance
shows and they say it's just dancing
it's just dancing and that's how they
move you increment by increment to the
point now where we saw in I think it was
San Antonio where they actually had
exposed fake breasts in front of
children they had men simulating sodomy
and then the craziest thing is there's a
journalist on Twitter right now arguing
with I think Taylor Hansen's name saying
uh or is it Tyler I don't Taylor saying
um it didn't happen you edited it's a
fake video despite the fact there's a
dozen of them now they're moving into
denial the craziest thing about this and
I want to give a shout out to project
Veritas when they did and give project
Veritas money I mean that because they
they're a non-profit and they rely on uh
everyone's support for doing this when
they put out this video from Chicago
where the dean of students is talking
about Kink education for children in a
skirt Francis Parker school I'm getting
from the people I know on the left
they're saying but Tim it's just sex ed
and I'm like no no hold on it's just
teaching children about reproduction
when you think it's appropriate for them
is very different from teaching them how
to lube something for Kink that is
something totally different and that's
what we're seeing with these all ages
drag shows I mean that's why I made
those podcasts back in October November
last year I called them groomer schools
and it's just been you know I of course
got blasted off of Twitter for this uh
back on Twitter thanks Elon uh don't
cuck this up now
um my gosh so here I am and I think
somebody backstage owes me money because
I said that but anyway
[Laughter]
anyway what I did was I I've just been
proved right again and again and again
okay okay grammar okay grammar and the
goal is this again this escalating I
said unconventional warfare this is so
important I talked to Tim earlier this
year the first time I wanted to show
this year with him I was like listen
political Warfare is the most important
concept you've never heard of
unconventional warfare political Warfare
this mid-level violence provocation is
so critical to understand because
they're giving you a choice they put a
drag queen oh it's just a story oh it's
just dancing and what you're going to do
is you're either going to give in at
which point they're going to enter into
their General generative themes
educational method into living clearly
strategic Defiance this is straight out
of their literature that they say is the
real goal of dragon Queen story we're
going to leave a trail of glitter that
will never come out of the carpets the
last sentence in that paper talking
about your kids brains
and then either you give into it and
they get to do that or you go too hard
and you you mess up and they make a
video of you looking bad and then they
start trying to smear you as an
anti-groomer or as rising anti-lgbt hey
this is the thought terminating cliche
so people don't think about it oh that's
bad don't think don't ask questions just
stop and say the person that's bad and
the goal is to get you to give in so
they get their way or overreact and
that's why I say drag Floyd is so
important to understand that they want a
drag queen to get attacked and they want
to make a huge amount of hay of it and
they want to create summer 2020 again
off of a drag queen or a trans person or
something like this meanwhile what are
they peppering the environment with this
is called in unconventional warfare
operational preparation of the of the
environment it used to be operational
preparation of the battlefield that's
why the intelligence Community is being
involved in this is so critical they
know this stuff and what are they doing
oh stochastic terrorism stochastic
terrorism stochastic terrorism everybody
who talks about this is a sarcastic
terrorist it's only a matter of time
until there's violence and what do all
the Articles do they wrap it up they're
like oh James Lindsay Tim Poole Jack
busovic all these people they're saying
groomer Marjorie Taylor green saying
groomer Lauren bobert groomer these
people are going to cause violence
they're going to have their stochastic
terrorism and then what are they going
to do oh and Elon Musk let them all back
on Twitter so then they're gonna get
control back of the media so they can
keep control of the dialogue and of the
narrative do you see that there is a
strategy there is a plan they they have
a plan this can be beaten just by
calling it out ahead of time so they
look like jerks when they do it they're
going to try to get control well that's
the thing yeah of course of course and
they may or may not get it but if you
don't know that this is happening to you
you're standing in what they might call
the wizard circle with a spell cast on
you don't know how can you say they're
trying to get control They removed Trump
from Office no by the way by the way on
his watch with Twitter Twitter
specifically
Elon Musk they're going to blow out Elon
Musk that's what I'm saying a hundred
percent you think he's over there in
Qatar begging for money because I think
all the advertisers are cut him off he's
bleeding Cash He said today was it that
Twitter could be bankrupt by May or
since May it's been heading towards
bankruptcy bankruptcy Cincinnati heading
towards bankruptcy the thing's what
bleeding five or seven million dollars a
year a day a day excuse me they're in
control they're in control right now the
administrative State controls the
Federal Government it's far bigger and
in more parts of of our life than
anybody ever imagined and you know the
Leviathan and it's got to be confronted
we can't and he can't confront it with
half measures anymore
you have to take it on that's why you
got to choke it down and say hey we're
going to zero the FBI the FBI gets no
money whatsoever zero okay the
Department of Justice hallelujah
hallelujah and the ATF through the DEA I
know we're at the Tim pool show with
with the great uh co-host but this is a
relatively conservative audience and
they're cheering to defund the FBI
because they understand the FBI is the
modern American gestapa defund
everything and the parks department
specifically I'm concerned about it
anyway I just wanted to add one more one
more single point about because this
latest trip by Elon Musk is also very
telling with the Optics with him being
seen with Jared Kushner the guy who of
course lobbied against Trump's very
populist policies the guy who of course
advocated for the bombing of a sovereign
country and got it done the guy who of
course negotiated better weapons deals
for Saudi Arabia he was there with him
so that kind of brings up to the point
what Bannon was making here that there's
a possibility that there is some bigger
money moves being made here well for
sure you said earlier Steve just a
minute ago that the administrative State
controls the government but I wonder
where they get their money the entire
government needs money the Federal
Reserve and where does the Federal
Reserve get their money they hit thing
they hit a thing and created well they
get it from the Swiss bank the federal
the bank for international settlements
what's that Swiss bank that deals out to
all these federal reserves around the
world and so we're basically being run
by this global banking cartel at the
moment but remotely remember the Federal
Reserve as the head of the cartel Just
Hits F9 and creates it okay they just
could they are putting you everybody in
this audience under 35 years old is
nothing more than a Russian surf you
don't own anything and you're not going
to own anything you'll be happy you'll
be happy they give you a little bit of
credit and they put you on the wheel of
samsara like a hamster right you just
Spin and you maybe get a little bit more
but right now even family formation is
later because it's tough it's tough for
a couple even to make it the the they've
taken what thirteen and a half trillion
dollars of net worth out of this economy
out of our middle class and working
class in the last nine months the
Federal Reserve here's the scam the
Federal Reserve just creates it just
creates it it's not backed by any bonds
they don't they can't sell bonds to
Japanese insurance companies or the
Chinese nobody buys it they create they
call monetize the debt that means it's
on your you're the full faith and credit
of the United States they create it and
the administrative State they'll take
all of it they can get how do you think
we got 31 trillion dollars on the on the
on the treasury nine trillion dollars on
the FED another 30 trillion dollars on
Social Security in in Medicaid and
another and contingent liabilities of a
hundred trillion dollars because the
administrative state has a funding
mechanism it's called the Federal
Reserve we have to End the Fed we should
not have
if you want freedom from the founding of
the country from the founding of the
country and to the founding of the
Federal Reserve almost the entire 19th
century was about populism in the fight
over currency in the definition of money
and who created it and they stopped that
because they realized the populist
movement was starting to get traction
with William Jennings Brian and others
right after after Andrew Jackson and
Lincoln being a national they said we
got to stop that okay the way they
stopped is the Federal Reserve we have
to to take down the administrative State
we have to grab the Federal Reserve by
the neck and choke it down right now
it's owned by do you understand your
currencies owned by 31 Banks 31 prime
Brokers owned the Federal Reserve create
it and make money off it and you live
like a pauper this can't happen we need
a revolution in this country and this
revolution's got to go this revolution's
got to go to the Railhead of where the
money is we've got to take control of
the Federal Reserve and choke down the
administrative State and anybody that's
not on that program is nothing more than
controlled opposition can we we almost
had that and Tim you were on the front
lines of this and you talk about this
really well but let me just kind of hand
it off to you in a sec because I'd love
your thoughts the Occupy Movement saw it
correctly in one way and incorrectly in
another way Tea Party Movement was
happening almost simultaneously because
there was a series of decisions that
were made by Hank Paulson Timothy
Geithner Ben Bernanke all after the 08
crisis they could have allowed the
system to recorrect not put in all this
fake money but they made a decision and
they knew exactly what they were doing
modern monetary Theory baby 800 billion
dollars of stimulus which used to be a
lot of money and we're going to engage
in a decade-long sugar high and the only
way we're going to end is in a Currency
Reset Bernanke Hank Paulson Timothy
Geithner three former Goldman Sachs guys
by the way knew exactly what was
happening Tea Party Movement saw it
through a conservative lens too big of
government cut the taxes we don't like
it occupy sought through more of a
left-wing lens they're both seeing the
same thing said it differently Trump was
the only candidate to be able to
capitalize he might disagree Tim a
little bit a little bit so how did I end
up at Occupy Wall Street I was on 4chan
and there was something called operation
Empire State Rebellion which had nothing
to do with left or right it was
hacktivists and it was I don't know just
random people on 4chan who were saying
like hey you know we've got an issue
with what's going on with the big
bailouts our lives were being screwed
over the economy's in the gutter and so
that somehow merged with a handful of
leftists who were organizing some kind
of Occupy Wall Street when I go down
there for the first time I was there
within the first couple of days
there was nobody there there was a
handful of people standing in the rain
but that next weekend which was the
second weekend of occupy I saw old
people with American flags an old couple
sitting on a couch with an American flag
behind their about their back they said
they were conservatives we all saw many
Libertarians I met Luke done at Occupy
Wall Street the problem is
I think a lot of the people on the right
immediately assumed that it was like a
leftist liberal or something wrong and
so what happens that first weekend is
Big second weekend is bigger but people
who have jobs people who are
conservative and libertarian were like
I've got to leave and I've got to go
home and the only people who are able to
stick around were marxists trust fund
kids well off and so the left ended up
taking everything over thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time